hello and to welcome to this video
playing my way from my way yeah we know
he know that that already okay so what
is he doing here it's transported to
this anti benoni and he actually goes
for the gambit line okay yeah recently
lost a game with that yeah if I play
this more often I should really study it
a bit just not just play it and hope for
the best yeah I know that it's correct
up to this point but not sure about the
continuation
a very logical play here by my way
centralizing yeah I think if he takes
takes the pawn back I should be fine so
didn't do that no maybe I get an A three
NV for him mmm yeah okay maybe he can go
a sixsome play d5 himself so i probably
have to prevent that before it's not
ideal but maybe just be three Bishop e2
and so on ok I hope III is actually
possible it looks a bit bit dodgy with
that we can see three night but don't
see anything concrete working for him
yeah that's it sorry history is strange
strange opening line it's very for me
very hard to accept that black should
have full compensation in this position
for a full central pawn okay I try to
trade this off very often that King's
Bishop can become a dangerous attacking
piece so trading it looks okay maybe he
can still play Bishop to a7 that sits
it's possible if he goes Bishop and 796
would be a funny funny move and probably
also a good move okay i'm here i wanted
to take with the pawn actually want to
keep them g forbes square controlled now
if he now goes back let's say to a seven
then he has to also very about d6 as a
possibility
hmm know that I don't know I don't
believe in that for black so case let's
see i can't think this is pretty clear i
have the very strong default square for
my queen next this is not a move to
think long about
b7 is also hanging yeah it looks it
looks like a good position for him for
white okay I can take be 70 m is this
something is there something that he has
you know I don't see ya we would reply
for black don't see a good reply okay
yeah yeah rupee 6 comes into
consideration here I take nine Texas is
looking a bit awkward but maybe really
do this first where is he going
rook takes f6 also something that can
become relevant not sure on which move
though maybe it is not really becoming
relevant yeah this one okay if I am I
can if like what is happening here I can
take g4 here night Teague's okay I can
think look we have six Bishop e2 is
there something with this probably not
it's not bad but ok but I don't see
really any reason not to snatch this and
then take on your form 94 is there a
tactic looking for no night you five I
think I can go right to the 60 I don't
see why not thirteen ninety-six the
addresses this is pretty big ok so it's
now some idea left for him night
somewhere f3 know so I see no reason why
not to do this also covering c4 at the
same time
black resins yeah there's nothing left
yeah I really really yep good game um I
really like this position for white I
don't really see blacks pick
compensation hear the engine finds an
improvement I guess on this night to be
six yeah this makes an awful lot of
sense d 5 is attacked and if i take
Bishop takes this is this is hanging
Bishop here maybe come on ship here and
now the engine gives this in test with
brutal equal play yeah like will
probably win the d5 pawn back so this is
okay for him yeah when I was forced some
how to play this a form maybe i'm not i
have here the computer actually wants to
play this which is quite myself now for
example so this was maybe a mistake yet
as a phone p 396 now was his opportunity
and now here after Bishop a3 I think
what should be better I am I would be
surprised if that's not the case I like
almost has to take now on a three and
this n96 was interesting not necessary i
can play book c1 or whatever it this is
an interesting move ook cheeks and then
night f5 and it's hard to believe that
this shouldn't be shouldn't be good for
white
an important point checking true yeah
well he went here and now it gets its
really it gets too bad i believe yeah
this is a tempo on the be porn and after
Queen D for its it's more or less more
or less going I think yeah stockfish is
also on 22.5 there the B part is also
very weak so these things take let's
just take everything you know 96 yeah
this is this opening line is interesting
I think it might be indeed a little bit
better for white but it's it's it's
tough to play I really lost a pretty
strong game only recently with this and
probably my very superficial knowledge
there is insufficient against against
people who know the opening and
connected ideas well nothing my way
didn't didn't know it so well okay well
thanks for watching